hello everybody I'm Jesse Waters along
with Judge Jeanine Pirro Harold Ford Jr
Dana Perino and V Greg Gutfeld It's Five
O'Clock in New York City and this is the
five
[Music]
heartbreaking Devastation in Hawaii at
least 36 lives have been tragically lost
after Hurricane force winds whipped up
wildfires that raged across the island
and reduced towns to Rubble people
forced to drive through hell on Earth to
flee one resident watching as the Flames
came dangerously close to his home
scorching nearly every building on a
street
as of this hour hundreds are presumed to
be missing bodies are being pulled from
the ocean after people had no choice but
to jump in to escape the flames and
thousands are scrambling for safety
Max Gordon's on the ground in Maui Max
yeah you got it there it's an island
paradise that was turned into a
hellscape you can see the field behind
me blackened by the fire the scent of
smoke hangs heavy in the air but there
is some good news at this hour this
morning we saw some rain roll through
much needed for this scorched Island
oh my gosh look at the harbor
oh my God
long time residents here shock at what
they saw people here in Maui have dealt
with just so much loss because of these
fires at least 36 people dead it's the
deadliest U.S Wildfire since the 2018
camp fire in California it's unclear
what sparked these fires on Maui but
officials here say that conditions have
been very dry and that winds from
passing Hurricane Dora hundreds of miles
to the South fanned the multiple
wildfires and caused them to spread
quickly gusts of up to 85 miles per hour
were reported grounding firefighting
aircraft some communities on Maui have
been decimated block after Block in the
historic Seaside town of Lahaina burned
to the ground in some cases people had
to jump into the ocean to escape the
flames and some are now left with
nothing
foreign
thousand people have been evacuated from
the island of Maui via air right now
Hawaiian Airlines is offering 19 tickets
just to get people to other islands and
today around 1500 people are expected to
leave the island via air back to you so
sad Max thank you now let's go to Rick
Reichmuth Fox Weather Center Rick hey
yeah just want to show you kind of the
setup of what caused all this to happen
we've talked about Hurricane Dora but
that's way to the south in fact it was
around 700 miles away you have this area
of high pressure to the north of it it's
those two in conjunction that really
funneled all the wins right through
you'll notice where they are now moving
past Hawaii and so the winds really
recalling down a lot and that's the good
news the weather at least now begins to
cooperate a little bit I want to just
show you a few before and after pictures
take a look at this of Lahaina before
and now take a look at the Lahaina
afterwards you see almost the entire
thing burn and I want to do this across
a couple different areas this is the
Outlets of Maui take a look at it before
and you go to after pretty much every
building in that entire area burned now
go to Banyan Court also in Lahaina
before and you go to afterwards and
again every one of the buildings gone
this all happened because those winds
were gusting as high as 80 miles an hour
and right in Lahaina one of those fires
right in Lahaina that's a larger
population area and then if some fires
also up here in up country not as much
population in that spot right now winds
have calmed down a little bit they're
around 20 to 25 miles an hour across the
area that certainly is Improvement one
thing I just want to show you we as of
yesterday six percent of the entire
state of Hawaii was in drought now that
number has gone up to 14 percent the new
monitor just came out yesterday but the
worst of that drought is right there on
Maui that's where we've got up to severe
drought and you can see it when you look
at the precipitation it's the one Island
here that is below average year-to-date
precipitation wise so and maybe a little
bit of rain coming in over the next few
days but they still have a deficit in
the rain guys and that's been a big part
of the problem all right thanks Rick
stay there let's bring back max Gordon
Max you're seeing something new here we
go
yeah we've got a Chinook helicopter here
it looks like it's uh carrying a bucket
full of water this is one of the very
important tools that firefighters use to
douse the flames and this is one of the
reasons why the firefighting efforts
were made so difficult by that high wind
essentially the wind grounded
helicopters like this Chinook admitted
unable to be used because it's just too
dangerous but you can see it now
circling around I'm not sure exactly
where this helicopter is going to be
making its bucket drop here or where
it's been picking up water but yeah this
is the first time we've seen the Chinook
in action I believe this is a National
Guard helicopter the National Guard has
been on the ground here aiding in the
search and rescue efforts and as you can
see they're now helping out with the
firefighting efforts as well Jesse all
right Max stay there we're going to take
it around the table Dana Perino has a
question Max that was wondering just
given what we know now I know this all
happened seemingly very quickly
yesterday and the fire looked like it
was far enough away that people could
take an assessment and decide whether to
leave but do you think there would have
been time for there to be for there to
have been an evacuation order or more
warning that the government could have
provided to people so that they could
have either saved their property or save
their lives
yeah so we had a combination of a lot of
different environmental factors at play
right so we had very dry conditions here
on the ground uh this part of Maui is in
a drought and then we had those high
winds and then we also had low relative
humidity so all that combined to create
a firestorm essentially and this fire
moved very very quickly you know uh I'm
not necessarily going to second guess uh
you know whether or not there should
have been evacuation orders or or when
um but you know when a fire starts
moving that quickly with 80 mile per
hour winds oftentimes there's not much
firefighters are able to do to stop the
flames and then unfortunately we saw the
fire move into the town of Lahaina go
from building to building block to block
to block when a fire gets going like
that especially with older buildings
this is a very historic area you know
it's a chain reaction it's like dominoes
you know we see building after building
just start to go down and unfortunately
we saw the town essentially decimated
all right Max Herald Ford Jr Max thanks
for the reporting two quick questions
for you first are there still people
stranded in places where they where they
want to evacuate we saw some reports of
that I'm hoping that's wrong
uh you know I haven't necessarily heard
of anybody still stranded I know that
evacuations are still ongoing uh the
county of Maui has been busing people
from the West Side uh over to the
airport just trying to get as many
people out as possible but search and
rescue operations are still ongoing
they're still looking for folks and one
thing that's making this a lot more
difficult is that Communications are
really spotty on the West Side cell
towers are down phone lines are down
power is out and so some people might
not be able to get in touch with their
loved ones a really harrowing situation
especially with officials saying that
the death toll could rise judge you know
Max it is a harrowing situation
certainly for people that were forced to
jump into the ocean because they felt
they had no other option but having been
in a National Emergency myself or a
natural emergency I should say one of
the things that people feel is that once
a search and rescue is over they have to
feel confident that someone is going to
come in and save them not just
emotionally from the trauma but
financially to allow them to build again
the Army Corps of Engineers uh I mean
what is the plan going forward once a
search and rescue is over will people be
allowed to come in and assist the people
from Hawaii
yeah you know a major disaster
declaration is going to unlock those
federal funds you know we're going to
have to have wait and see what happens
next uh from here I think right now
we're still in the assessment phase just
seeing what's been broken finding the
people who are missing and then we're
going to get to those next steps but I
think what is very clear right now is
that it's going to take a long time for
a lot of folks here to recover you know
we've got more than 200 structures that
have been burned down in Lahaina alone
people have lost their homes they've
lost everything a lot of things can't be
replaced especially the lives the 36
people who have been confirmed dead Greg
yeah I know that the variables of a very
dry summer and these strong winds uh
created this Devastation but how did it
start I mean what are the usually these
things are man-caused there could have
been volcanic activity but do they have
any idea
right now we don't know what caused
these fires this is not necessarily a
volcanic island it is a part of a
volcanic chain but there aren't any
active volcanoes here so right now we're
gonna have to wait for word on officials
on why these fires started
okay let's take it over to Rick Last
Words yeah the active volcano is on the
big island so not there in Maui but
probably also when you've got winds
going this High very easily could have
just knocked power line down power lines
down which would cause a spark and in
that dry vegetation get that fire going
really fast so way too early probably to
figure out exactly what it is but
because there were also a few different
fires those winds likely knocking down
power lines would certainly be a good
suspect for it Rick thank you Max you as
well let's keep Hawaii in our thoughts
and prayers hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else